(audience applauding)
- I love this!
You look so cute.
(audience applauding)
Look at you with your drop crotch.
I like it.
I love a good drop crotch
like, overall situation.
- Yes I do. I really do.
- It's so nice.
Well, thank you again for
being a part of our like
season three premier of
New York City music video.
That was so awesome.
- Yes, yes. Thank you for having us.
You know my cousin works here
- No. What?
- Yeah, Glenn. Glenn
Vereen works on your show.
- Oh my Gosh
- There he is right there.
- [Kelly] I didn't know that.
- [Ben] Yeah, That's right.
- What
- [Ben] Yeah. My cousin.
- You are so hysterical
[Kelly] I didn't even
know that from the opening
[Kelly] Oh my gosh.
Well we let, see
we have...we like good people.
We have good taste
- [Ben] You do.
And also, you worked with my godson.
- Oh yeah, Usher. I didn't know
that Usher was your godson.
I had no idea.
Do you ever, do you love giving him advice
or are you terrified of that?
- No, no, no, no.
I love giving advice.
He still don't take it.
(laughter)
But in the beginning he was all
it was all like,
But give me...but pops,
pops, pops, pops pops on me.
See my,
actually my daughter discovered him,
brought Usher to me, and next thing I know
all my dance tapes are
going off the shelf.
I'm going, what's going on?
She said, "Dad he just want to know
a little something about it."
Next though she moves to Atlanta.
Next thing I know
we're going down one day and
he picked me up in his Jeep, he says,
"Hey pops I want you to hear something"
He puts on the song
called "You Make Me Wanna"
(singing)
So I sit back or sit in the
backseat. I told my daughter,
I said, sit back. So she said, "why?"
I said, he's about to blow up.
Next thing I know, Usher.
♪ You make me wanna
leave the one I'm with ♪
Those are my moves, those are my moves
(laughter)
(applause)
- Give him crap for it. I love it.
Well, wait, I want to,
before you leave,
I want to talk about this
because you're on B Positive.
So let's talk about it. So
what, who are you on B Positive?
- I love B Positive.
Thank you, thank you Chuck Lorre.
Thank you for calling me.
Chuck Lorre is a king of...
...kind of king of TV.
I'm working with an amazing cast and
Annaleigh Ashford.
Oh God, I'm so excited. So nervous.
- No no no.
But you play a professor right?
- I play a professor.
He's Peter, Peter Bernard Yates.
- Yates. Well that's a good last name
He's a professor who's
retired to The Valley,
The Valley Hill where we, you know,
it's a retirement home.
- [Kelly] Yeah
- And I'm working with some great people.
You know, I work with
007 Jane Seymour, my God.
- Oh my gosh. I love her.
You're talking about 007.
I'm talking about Dr.
Quinn Medicine Woman.
What.
Boom.
- Linda Lavin, Jim Beaver, I
mean the list goes on and on.
And we sit there, and,
I want to thank first of all,
I want to thank the crew.
You got to thank these people
for the work that they do.
If it wasn't for them,
we wouldn't be doing what we're doing.
- Absolutely.
Isn't this an Emmy Award
winning crew right here?
- Wait till you see my crew.
And also, you got to thank
the caterers and the wardrobe department
who make it all happen for
us, to allow us to sit there,
Annaleigh and all of us to sit there and
Thomas, do our thing.
And for the writers, I mean,
Chuck's got such an
amazing staff of writers.
We sit there and they come down and they,
you can't have an audience
right now. So he comes down,
he and the writers and the producers,
and they sitting there to watch the show
and they start laughing,
they're laughing at their own jokes.
- That's amazing.
- I sit there laughing at them,
laughing at their own jokes,
because they're really funny.
It's really funny stuff.
- Look how hysterical I was here.
- Yeah
I've never done a regular on a sitcom
I've been a guests, and I did
Will Smith, Fresh Prince of Bel Air
where I still get to
hit him upside the head
[Unintelligible]
And so, I had never had the experience
of sitting down and doing a sitcom and...
- It's cool if you've got good chemistry,
it's a good cast right?
- Yeah, oh man, it's a wonderful cast.
It's magic.
- [Kelly] That's awesome
- Coming to work is,
I mean,
coming to work is beautiful.
(music)
(applause)